[Music]
okay everybody i'm so excited today
because i
am joined by daniel radcliffe aka craig
aka prince tronsley aka reverend ezekiel
brown and steve buscemi
aka god aka edward [ __ ] shoveler aka
benny the teen how you guys doing today
very good great intro comprising all of
the characters nicely done
thank you um so daniel did you find
any of prince chancellor or craig in
reverend ezekiel brown
i think there's probably some
similarities between craig
and ezekiel brown in their sort of
earnestness and um they're sort of
sincerely wanting to work to make the
world better
um but i think uh craig is a lot more
sort of helpless
and nervous than ezekiel brown is i mean
zeke is not you know
he's not he is he has nerves as well but
i think he's a lot more of a capable
human being
um and the the great thing about him as
opposed to translate is that
seancely was too psychotically stupid to
ever learn or grow
from anything that happened to him um so
it's nice playing character who is like
affected by the world around him
yeah and that's what's so impressive
seeing you do all these different type
of characters and same for you steve
steve did you find any famous figures or
characters
in media that inspired your portrayal of
benny the team
i mean obviously the character is you
know loosely
sort of based or i'm not even based but
there's like a joke about you know like
benny the teen there's billy the kid and
um but i didn't really want to base it
on on anybody real i just
you know we have such wonderful writers
and i just love you know the character
that they
came up with and that you know besides
i mean i think all three of the
characters i've played now
they're not you know none of them are
like
overly bright but they all
have you know uh something like these
character traits that are just really
really interesting
um i like that this character i think he
this is like the most engaged
you know i mean god was sort of you know
on his own
and sort of right disinterested and like
not knowing like
in way over his head eddie i loved
because he was a family man but very
simple
and you know trusting and just um
sort of uh just trying to get by whereas
benny
you know he's he was a real hot shot you
know he's still he's still living in his
glory days
and i think he still has a lot to offer
and he does help them
you know along along the way
um but you know he's very selfish and
ultimately he's out he's out for himself
yeah and that's what's so impressive to
me about this show is like just you
explain that how like
in depth these characters are and i
think people
also fall in love with characters and
then miss them the next season so i'm
wondering
will we ever see some kind of connection
between the seasons or maybe little
easter eggs has that ever been kind of
discussed
daniel maybe you can answer that i mean
there's a couple of what i would
describe as like easter eggs
uh in in this season later on um
but i don't think we will ever get to
the point where we are linking them
directly but i also don't
know um there might be some genius piece
of writing that one of our guys has up
his sleeve that can somehow do that
um but i i also like i mean part of the
joy of it is that it is that it changes
all the time so
um and if there is a theme that we have
it's just
um you know a group of people working
together
against seemingly impossible odds and
odds that are in fact
impossible but trying anyway um that's
sort of become the thematic link at
least
yeah i definitely see that and i love
that answer and
steve i love the episodes you directed
in season
two do you enjoy being behind the camera
as much as you do in front of it and
are you gonna be directing any episodes
this season yeah i directed two episodes
this season
which was nice because i mean i don't
get to direct a lot and every time i do
it i feel like i'm doing it again for
the first time so to be able to
do two like during the second one i
think i was a little bit more
relaxed you know but we don't have a lot
of time to shoot and then plus i'm
playing a character in it and so that's
always a challenge
but it means i get to work with all the
actors you know it means i
you know really get to uh and be
involved in every aspect
of the production and i really i really
do enjoy
enjoy that so i hope i hope to do more
of it you know
yeah and you do an amazing job obviously
at both
and daniel that that's going to come
with the question for you would you ever
consider directing i think people would
love to see you kind of take a shot
behind the camera
oh i definitely would i definitely want
to um
i think from the first thing i direct
will probably be something i'm not also
in um just because i feel like as a
first-time director i would be
so worried and nervous about that but i
really want to focus on it
um but yeah 100 i would i i've been
around people directing for for so long
now that i
i feel like i hopefully have learned
enough that i could bring something to
the table and like yeah i i would really
love to at some point oh that's that's
really exciting to hear
i would love to see that and steve i
think you could answer this question but
when fans see both of your names
as executive producers of the show i
think most people always go what does it
really mean like what what does that
mean for you guys on this show
right question well um i mean
[Music]
i i mean we have access we have you know
weak i think we could be as involved as
as we want
certainly during during production when
we're you know when we're acting
so much it's hard you know to like
to to also do that to that role but
mainly i think with dan and i it's
especially in the third season was just
you know getting in on more of the
conversations you know with
the writers and uh you know just being
being consulted and just looking
at you know at the episodes as as we
were
uh as they were being edited and then
just
i just try and be helpful in you know
whatever way i can if you know
i mean i'm just i just make myself
available but i also don't want to
you know i'm not interested in kind of
being like overpowering saying no we
need this and
we have to do that and i want this it's
yeah i'm just i'm just really there to
support yeah i mean i would say the same
thing i think once once it gets to
production
you're mostly uh just focusing on the
acting
um and yeah and it means you get access
and an input
in pre-production both with you know um
with casting stuff whereas with just how
the scripts are coming together you know
you you
you're in a position that most actors
aren't in terms of like getting that
level of you know consultation stuff so
that's that's lovely but yeah once
things start you kind of just focus on
on the acting yeah i think that's a
great answer
to like life's biggest mystery so thank
you guys for that uh
before i let you guys go what would you
say
to fans to get them excited about season
three like what's your favorite thing
about this season
um it's honestly like i loved
watching everybody else in their parts
this year like i feel like this
season just has got something fantastic
for everyone um and i'm really i'm
you know i i'm really excited for people
to see uh john bass and more of
him in this season than i think people
have seen before and you know
there's a part for him this year that is
just spectacular and he really uh he
really
he nails it yeah i think it's
you know i think what the show does so
well is is the relationships
you know and and putting these
characters in
situations or positions that you know
then they're at they're at great odds to
like to
overcome and this is no exception and
this you know this
season gets pretty dark towards the end
the characters are forced in situation
that they have to do something
horrible if they if they want to survive
and um and i will mention
that uh in episode four i think it is
dan has an incredible
dance number that is not to be missed oh
that's amazing that
that's breaking news right here says
don't that's a costume it's a whole it's
a whole thing
amazing so everyone you're hearing it
from them first that
miracle workers out oregon trail on
tuesday on tbs make sure to check it out
daniel steve thank you so much for
joining me today and i hope to talk to
you guys again in the future one day
thank you take care thank you have a
good day you too
have a great one